Hello, I'm William
Zaloga. I'm a DO,
a pathologist at
the Arkansas campus
of NYIT, and this
is a talk of the
pathology of skeletal
muscle in P-POM-1.
I mean, here's
my email. If you,
feel free to send
me any comments or
questions, or unless
you're here on the
Arkansas campus,
Come up to my office,
room 424F, or you
can call me at
870-680-8899. That's
my office number.
Okay, let's start.
So, the objectives are
going to start with
a brief review of normal
muscles and reactions
that occur, such as
degeneration and atrophy,
and then we're going
to go over some
diseases that are categorized
as different types
of muscle and nerve
diseases, and sometimes
they of systemic
manifestations as well.
For example,
this group here is
going to involve
neuron and
inherited disorders.
This group here is
going to involve
disorders of metabolism
and and Inherited
Mitochondrial Disorders
and what's called Ion
Channel Myopathies,
down here these are
going to be discussing
inflammatory
disorders that will
affect muscles and other
tissues of the body
and down here we're
going to discuss some
autoimmune disorders
and this is just
another look at that,
a brief review of normal
injury and reactions
and then under
inherited we're going to
look at these disorders
inflammatory those
disorders and these
autoimmune disorders down
here and that at the
end there's a some
miscellaneous map that
these that we'll look at.
This slide has a
picture of electron
micrograph of a muscle
part of a muscle fiber
in longitudinal
section and here's a
diagram that goes over
a different parts of
what's called the
sarcomere and And it
talks about various
structures that are
visualized when we
look at this EM image,
such as the H
-band, the I-band,
the A-band,
which appears in
lighter and
darker regions,
the Z-disc. And these
function as a unit,
the sarcomere, in series
in a muscle fiber,
which is a muscle cell
with lots of sarcomers
in series to move,
to allow movement
and stabilization of
myosin seen here in red,
these dark lines
here, and actin, which
you can barely see in
this lighter region.
And there's other proteins
that are associated
with stabilizing these
structures within
the sarcomere. In the
Z-disc, that would
be alpha-actinin. And
one thing is that at
the M line, that's
where creatine kinase,
or sometimes called
creatine phosphokinase,
is bound. And that
serves as an ATP reserve
for the muscle, which
uses a lot of ATP.
And it drives a
reaction where ADP with
phosphocreatine under
the action of creatine
kinase develops into
ATP plus creatine.
And creatine under
the same enzyme,
creatine kinase, can
be turned back into
phosphocreatine. And
that's a muscle energy
store because ATP
would be used up in a
muscle within seconds
unless there was some
sort of backup to
provide that extra ATP.
Here are the two
types of myofibers
that exist in
muscles, and there's
type 1 and type 2,
and they have some
descriptions here,
and some examples
of where these
muscles are found.
Paraspinal muscles,
soleus muscles. so muscles
that maintain the
posture of a person and
then there's other
muscles which react more
quickly to stimulation
okay so that's why
they're called slow slow
twitch and fast twitch
type muscles slow
twitch have high levels
of mitochondria and
they have sustained
contractions through
oxidative phosphorylation,
and they're utilized
in endurance training.
The fast-twitch fibers
have low levels of
mitochondria, they
quickly fatigue, and they
use anaerobic
glycolysis, and they're
used in weight resistance
and sprinting, and
when you look
at a histologic
stain, stained
with, in this case,
NADHTR, that's
tetrazoleum reductase
with, well,
NADH, you know,
that's the reduced
form of ***.
That stains a flash
frozen tissue sample,
and so they need
to be specially
handled so that these
things will show the
various staining of
the tissue section.
More densely darker
appearance of the stain,
and this is a cross
-section, so we see a
cross-section of the
different myofibers.
Those are going to be
the type 1 oxidative
fibers with a lot
of NADH activity.
And then we have
type 2 that show
the non-oxidative
fibers, but they do
show some purple
speckling. And the
thing to notice
here is you see
what's called a
checkerboard pattern.
So the motor neurons
that are supplying
this muscle have a
small group of slow
twitch fibers and
a small group of
fast twitch fibers,
and they're intermixed
like this. And
here's a nice chart
that goes over the
major points of the
type 1 and type 2
muscle fibers. And
this is a review of
normal histology.
This is a cross
-section of the muscle
fibers, and you see
there's connective
tissue that had different
names, perimuseum
around the whole
bundle of fibers,
endomuseum around
individual muscle
fibers. And so
there's a cross
-section. Here's a
longitudinal view.
The longitudinal view
we can look at first.
There's the nuclei
that you see at the
periphery, not just
under the plasma
membrane, the sarco lemma
of the muscle fiber,
and these are multi
-nucleated, very long
cells, that's why
they're called fibers.
And those sarcomeres
we talked about with
the different lines
that show up on EM,
you can see them
in the longitudinal
sections. In the cross
-sections, you see
the multiple nuclei
at the periphery and
then the elements of
the muscle fibers on
H&E stain or protein
cell stained pink.
And then this is a normal
muscle physiology
that can...
Okay, so during a
contraction there's going
to be a motor nerve
from a motor neuron
that will send an
action potential to the
motor end plate of
the muscle, myofiber.
And when When the
action potential
arrives, it will
stimulate the increase of
calcium that will
release acetylcholine
from the vesicle and
the axon terminal.
Then the acetylcholine
will process synapse
and interact with
the acetylcholine
receptor on the
sarcolemma of the muscle.
That will travel
through the sarcolemma
and then interact
with receptors on the
sarcolemma and the
sarcoplasmic reticulum.
The reticulum has
a lot of the major
store of calcium
within the muscle cell.
And these
receptors, the DHPR,
which is dihydropyridine,
and the ryanidine
receptor here, allow
for the increase in
sarcoplasmic, a lot of
increase in sarcoplasm
with increase of calcium
within sarcoplasm
which allows for muscle
myofibrile contraction
which are the elements
within the muscle
fiber that contract
which are the myosin
and the actin and then
here's the continuation
okay so I mentioned
there's going to be an
increase in calcium.
Calcium will bind to
troponin and then that
will allow movement of
tropomyosin, another
protein, there's a lot
of different proteins
within the muscle
fiber, to move and allow
the head of the myosin
fiber, which contains
ADP and ATP, to interact
with the binding
site on actin and once
that occurs then there
can be movement of
the myosin head along
actin and that produces
shortening of the
troponin I'm sorry the
myosin and actin fibers
which produces
contraction when ATP is
restored after what's
called the power ******,
then when ATP is
restored, then there can
be detachment of the
head of myosin from the
binding site on actin
and the process can
start all over again
and calcium is released
and can be re
-sequestered in the
sarcoplasmic reticulum
for the next contraction.
Think about this one.
All right, now
we're going to talk
about myogenic
injury, what's called
myopathic injury,
and that's contrasted
to neurogenic in
just a little bit.
So with myogenic
injury, there's
going to be a segment
or just part of
a myofiber or
muscle cell that
undergoes
degeneration, and with
degeneration, there
will be regeneration.
So, part of the
myofiber will undergo
necrosis, and with
that, there will
be release of
creatine kinase into
the blood from
damaged cells, so that
will be a marker
of a blood test.
And if you look
under the microscope,
you'll see macrophages
that will remove
damaged components,
and that's called
myofagocytosis.
With regeneration,
there's going to be
activated satellite cells
that are near the
nuclei of the myofiber
and they will those
are myocyte stem cells
and once they're activated
they will differentiate
into new nuclei
that will govern the
repair of that myofiber
they'll stain basophilic
if you look under
the microscope which
will appear a little bit
maybe purple a little
more not not as much
pink and or orange
pink not as he is in a
phillic but what's called
basophilic a little
more purple under the
microscope because
there's a high level of
RNA that's being
produced and with with
disease complete
regeneration might not be
possible because that
chronic disease process
might outpace the
regenerative capacity of the
tissue or due to the
extent of the damage.
Myofibrohypertrophy
is a physiologic
response to
exercising, but it
can be associated
with diseases.
And we'll look
at one of those.
Then this line down
here, it's just
referring that in
disease, certain
inclusions, and
there's some are listed
here. Help as clues
to the diagnosis.
Okay.
And this goes over
neurogenic injuries.
And these are
the histologic
sections which
can be seen.
And I already mentioned
that there will
be a checkerboard
pattern seen in D.
If you state it for
enzyme within into the
type 1 and type 2
myofibers. It should be
small groups that are
interspersed within a
muscle, and these are
all cross-sections.
And these two cross
-sections are showing
disorders that occur.
So any disorder
that's going to
interrupt the motor
neuron supplying
the various groups
that it supplies
within a muscle will
undergo a reaction
where they will become
atrophic and this
will be seen as a
group, whatever that
nerve is applying,
as flattened and
angular shapes.
Then
with re-innervation,
what is happening
is that the motor
nerves that are adjacent
to the groups of fibers
that are undergoing
denervation and
atrophy will send
sprouts to those
motor fibers, to those
myofibers, which are
undergoing denervation
and atrophy, and then
resupply them. So
these spouts will
allow them to be
restored, so the proteins
and the function of
those fibers will be
restored. However,
this checkerboard
pattern is going to be
lost, and that large
group from whatever
the nerve was, was
applying all the adjacent
myofibers, will
turn this into very
large groups of the
same myofiber type, and
so you lose your
checkerboard pattern.
That's called fiber
type grouping. Alright,
now these two histologic
images, these are
H&E stains, so you see
pink, orange is pink,
sometimes it's more
pale than others
of all the proteins
within these cells,
compared and
contrasted of
neurogenic versus
myopathic injuries,
it could be
myogenic as well.
And we talked about
these two already, but
this contrasts them.
So, with neurogenic
injury, what we're
going to see is that
flattening of a group of
myofibers that the nerve
was supplying, and
I'm outlining it here,
and then the other
ones surrounding it.
Some of them may
become hypertrophy, you
know, larger than you
would normally see because
they're, the
hypertrophy is occurring
based on the stresses
that the muscle is
subject to, and these
fibers are to contribute
because they don't
have the innervation,
but they can be restored
and myofiber grouping
will occur, as we
talked about before.
And then we have
myopathic injury.
What you're
going to see here
is that there
will be necrosis
and there will
be regeneration
and just a segment.
So all of these in
here, you can see some
of them are small,
some of them are darker
than others, some of
them are more pale. So,
with necrotic cells,
you'll see them
lose their stain and
these two might be
an example here
of cells that are
becoming necrotic
and you see a lot of
them becoming very
small and shrinking.
And also, the
cytoplasm will
condense and
become irregular.
Here there is some
irregularity of
the staining and
you don't see, well
that looks irregular
and shrunk,
lighter here,
darker here.
So there's going
to be increased
variability of
the fiber size.
There is variability
here, but that has
a characteristic
pattern of this group.
They're flattened
and angular.
And they'll increase
variability,
and then with
regeneration,
that will show increased
central nucleation, so
the nuclei of myofibers
are normally supposed
to be at the periphery.
Here we have central
nucleation and it's
more basophilic because
of RNA initially,
but then it becomes
hyperchromatic and then
the nuclei will become
more peripheral.
So these are more
darkly intense
staining than
the normal pink
staining that
you see here,
and some of them are
hypertrophic. Then
you see the nuclei
being more peripheral.
This one is a little
bit more early in
its regenerative phase.
And these ones down
here are very early
during regeneration.
And you see some of
them, they have that
basophilic color
where they look a bit
more purple, and these
can recover. Okay,
here's the list of
inherited diseases of
skeletal muscle. There
are many, many diseases
of skeletal muscle,
so we can't go through
them all. But we'll go
over some important ones
or ones that are
significant just because
of the significant
illness that they cause.
Okay, inherited
refers to genetic,
so a path from
parent to child.
Down here we have
congenital ones, so you
probably understand that
congenital are present
at birth, and they may
be genetic, or there
can be some environmental
cause, such as
a teratogen that the
person was exposed to.
It doesn't have
to be inherited.
These other ones are
inherited. there's
abnormal genes are
being passed and so
we'll start with this
one all right spinal
muscular atrophy has
several there are
several different types
that were discovered
SMA1 is a progressive
disease and the
most severe is also
called Wardnick
Hoffman disease usually
has a childhood onset
it's inherited,
autosomal recessive,
and because it's a
genetic disorder, it's
going to be loss of
function of a gene.
So I guess what's
important here is to
remember the
demographics, so we have
childhood, and then how
it's going to present,
and then since it's
inherited, what
might be the genetic
disorder that's actually
causing it. Maybe
not so much the,
unless I talk about
it, or it's stressed
or highlighted, but
the genetic disorder
here, it's underlined.
And it does cause
effect in the splicey
zone, so RNA splicing
might not be working
appropriately.
What happens is that
there's a loss of
motor neuron innervation,
and that will result
in muscle weakness,
so that's presentation
and atrophy, and it
will be denervation
of skeletal muscles.
So you're going to
be looking for fiber
-type grouping if a
biopsy is done, but
it's important to know
the clinical features
so you'll know if
a biopsy is something
you want to do. occurs
in infants generally
with a, and remember
floppy infant,
generalized hypotonia,
little muscle tone,
within four months of
birth, usually death
by two, three years.
So for diagnosis,
a biopsy can be
performed, and because
it's a denervation,
you'll see lots of
groups with flattened
aneurous cells,
and then you might
see hypertrophied
cells around that that
are taking over the
muscle function.
And eventually
you'll see fiber-type
grouping as these extend
their axons to the
damaged fibers that
have lost their axons.
So that's what you'll
see characteristically.
And these larger
cells, they're
going to be retaining,
those are the
cells retaining
their innovation.
Okay, next is
muscular dystrophies.
And once again,
they are genetic
disorders. There
is two of the most
common, which are
Duchenne muscular
dystrophy and Becker
muscular dystrophy.
And they are
linked because they
involved this
gene location,
it's an X
-linked disorder,
and it encodes
a protein called
dystrophin, which
is one of the
sarcoplasmic proteins
important for
stabilizing
contraction of muscles.
It's a progressive
muscle weakness due
to damage as the
child develops and
wasting, usually
beginning in early
childhood. Duchesne
is more severe than
Becker's, usually death
by 20 to 30 years,
so demographics
are important to
remember. Becker is
milder later in onset.
And here are two diagrams
which go over normal
structures is bound
below the sarcolemma
or the plasma membrane
of the myofiber and
how it connects to the
extracellular matrix.
There's a protein
here called dystrophin
and complexes associated
with that, laminin
and all these proteins
here that help us
transmit forces to the
extracellular matrix as
contraction occurs
from actin and myosin.
If myocytes degenerate
when there's an
abnormal dystrophin
or it's absent and
there's going to be
progressive micro myocyte
damage that occurs
over time and it's
going to exceed the
regenerative capacity
because as contraction
occurs without
this strong connection
and also the
stabilization to the
extracellular matrix, a
lot of the force is
going to be transmit
to the plasma membrane,
and that's going
to produce repeated
damage of myofibers.
And they will regenerate
over time, but
they might not be
able to regenerate
completely as the
disease progresses.
This is another
diagram, which is
showing a lot of
the same thing.
You have actin and
dystrophins attachment
to that, and there's
proteins that attach
that to the plasma
membrane, and then other
proteins that are
going to attach it to
the extracellular
matrix proteins as well,
X-linked recessive,
and it results in
an absent dystrophy
gene. So that's
not present at all,
and that results
in chronic muscle
damage with usage.
And so you just need
to think about the
muscles that have a lot
of usage. Those might be
the ones that, for the
heart, for example,
or because
this is present
within cardiac muscle.
And the muscles
of, you know, like
with walking or
posture, you know,
those sorts of
muscles like that.
And well, those are
going to be the ones
where it's affected.
Later on, there will
be other muscles. There
will be the respiratory
diaphragm, which
has a lot of muscle
activity and that will
become damaged over
time as well, but
we'll talk about that.
and here's what you see
on the histopathology
so these are individual
myofibers that
are going to be affected
they could be type 1
type 2 and so early
in the disease you'll
see that segmental
myofiber degeneration
because it's a myopathic
disease so it'll be a
mixture of atrophic
fibers so these small
ones that are becoming
lighter as proteins
are not there's not as
much proteins that are
organized there to
maintain the stain.
Here's one regenerating.
You see that irregular
staining and you see
a more central nucleus
here so there's
regeneration going on and
then it doesn't look
like a group, it's just
a mixture of
hypertrophied, degenerating
myofibers.
And then you
see this here.
As these myofibers
degenerate, it'll be
replaced by fibrous
and fatty tissue, and
that's called fatty
infiltration as disease
progresses. And this
causes what's called
pseudohypertrophy. For
example, I said those
are going to be the
muscles that have a lot
of usage, you know,
as a child develops.
The ones for posture
and stabilizing
posture, I mentioned the
torso, walking,
things like that.
the remaining myofibers
will have prominent
variation in size,
small atrophic and large
hypertrophy, and then
fatty infiltration
and fibrous tissue that
infiltrates as well.
Here is a sign that
helps with the diagnosis,
and if you remember
the demographic skin,
it occurs at an early
age. It's X-linked, so
it'll be males
predominantly, and the life
expectancy will be
about 25 to 30 years.
First, there'll be
weakness of pelvic
girdle muscles, so once
again, muscles that
are retaining posture
and being used a
lot, and then extend of
the shoulder muscles,
you know, for
movement of the arms.
Then, of course, calf
muscles are going to
be affected. There'll
be weakness and
pseudohypertrophy. So,
it'll seem weak, but
they will have enlarged
muscles, and that's
due to the fat and
the fibrous tissue.
And one of the signs
that we discovered
a long time ago was
what's called Gower's
Maneuver. And a
patient with muscle
weakness will attempt
to arise from a supine
or seated position
on the floor, and
they push themselves
up or climb up their
legs with their
hands because of the
muscle weakness. That's
Gower's Maneuver.
Okay, Duchenne muscular
dystrophy. Clinically,
you'll see proximal
muscle weakness,
pseudohypertrophy of
the calf muscles, and
we talk about why
that is, and explain
Gower's maneuver, and
you'll see Gower's sign.
And you can develop
later as the
disease progresses
worsening respiratory
reserve, and I
explain that as well.
Cardiomyopathy, because
their dystrophin is
present in the heart
muscle, and there's a
small amount in nerve
cells of the brain, so
there can be some
intellectual impairment.
Later in disease,
early, I'm sorry,
there'll be increased
serum creatinine
kinase as the muscles
are damaged, and
damaged muscles
will release their
creatine, when I
say creatinine, It's
not creatinine. It's
creatine kinase.
Creatinine is a breakdown
product of
creatine phosphate,
and it's a cyclic
form that is filtered
in the kidney
and through the
blood, and it can be
used to measure GFR
in patients. So
that's creatinine.
Death may result,
but commonly
results from respiratory
insufficiency in
the 20s and 30s.
The treatment currently
is supportive.
There have been
efforts to manipulate
the condition that's
causing it, which
is an RNA splicing
disorder. Okay,
now there's Becker
muscular dystrophy.
And once again, it
affects a dystrophin
gene, so there's a
mutation. It's also X
-linked recessive,
but there's a partial
function of the dystrophin
protein. So it's
less severe, has a
slower progression,
presents later, may have
a normal life expectancy,
and instead of
presenting early in
childhood, he usually
starts presenting
adolescence or even
into adulthood.
The treatment,
once again, is
still supportive
care. Okay,
here's a question over
some of the stuff we
went over. It's quite
a bit, but should be
able to do this, so
maybe try to answer the
question. The next slide
is an answer, so if
you want to answer
it now, that would be
good, but Or you can
just look at the answer.
But we'll just
go over a few
things. Four-year
-old boy, so child,
tires easily,
falls a lot, weakness,
pelvis, arms, and
large calf muscles.
So you kind of already
know what it is.
Serum creatine kinase.
Biopsy is done.
Shows mark variation
and size and shape
of the muscle fibers.
Muscle necrosis,
regeneration,
fibrosis.
So, what's the most
likely eventual cause
of death? So we're
talking about DMD, and
we mentioned that
the respiratory
insufficiency in the
20s and 30s was the most
common cause of death
in these individuals.
Okay, hearty malaphyde
is common as well.
Okay, now myotonic
dystrophy, so you see
the name here, myotonic,
so there's going to
be some myotonous that
might be involved,
and that would be a
good sign to remember.
And it's inherited again,
autosomal dominant and a
trinucleotide
repeat onset.
twenty to four years.
This triplet expansion
involves myotonin
protein kinase,
there's the gene,
and once again an RNA
splicing disorder.
What it does is cause
a disorder of chloride
channels. Okay, those
are involved with muscle
relaxation, and that
leads to myotonia.
So it's an ion channel,
ion channelopathy.
Myotonia is an
inability to relax
your muscles. There's
a slow relaxation
phase, prolonged
contraction.
So it commonly
presents, and this
is a sign to
remember, grip
myotonia, can't
relax, sustain grip.
There is progressive
progressive muscle
wasting and weakness,
and these are some other
signs that you can
develop their chloride
channels all over the
place in your body.
And there can be arrhythmias
and cardiomyopathy,
increase serum CPK
as their muscle
damage occurs from
progressive muscle wasting.
Like I said, I
said channelopathy,
also called ion
channel myopathy,
like myotonic dystrophy.
Okay, so these are
inherited again, and
depending on the channel
that is affected, they
can produce different
signs and symptoms.
So they can produce
hypertonia or hypotonia.
There is subclassification
of some of them
based on the potassium
levels that are
present in the blood.
It can be hyperkalemic,
hypokalemic, normokalemic,
and those are
in conditions called
periodic paralysis.
So the clinical
manifestations, you know,
because it depends on
the ion channels and
where they're located
in the body, can produce
epilepsy, migraines,
movement disorders,
cerebellum dysfunction,
peripheral nerve
disease, muscle disease,
so that there can be
various systemic signs.
And these are
some examples.
This is a calcium
channel, and there's a
lot of different
proteins involved with
calcium channels,
this one down here as
well, and there's a
mutation, and that's
the most common
cause of hypokalemic
paralysis, so low
potassium with paralysis.
This mutation
here, that was
also present in
myotonic dystrophy
that we just
talked about,
and its expression
is decreased
in myotonic
dystrophy, okay?
So this is like a
repeat of what we just
talked about. Here is a
channel that regulates
calcium release
from a sarcoplasmic
reticulum, and they are
involved with various
disorders, including
congenital myopathy,
a congenital myopathy
-like central core
disease, and another
one called malignant
hyperthermia that
we'll talk about next.
malignant hyperthermia.
So as the name implies,
there's going to be
fever, a high fever
that's involved, and
it can be very severe.
And it is rare,
but there can be
and it's inherited,
there can be
life-threatening
skeletal muscle
contractions and
channelopathy, due to
this channelopathy.
The pathogenesis
is autosomal dominant
because these
individuals will
inherit a mutation of
the ryanidine receptor
and that's involved
in controlling calcium
release from the
sarcoplasmic reticulum.
This increased calcium
release follows
administration of
halogenated inhaled
anesthetics and also
succinylcholine
which is used for
temporary paralysis
during certain procedures
like antitracheal
intubation and
others, many others.
It has rapid onset
and short duration
of muscle
relaxation, which
is a reason people
like to use it.
The mechanism is
that those chemicals
interact with the
mutated receptor and
cause increased
calcium efflux, and
that leads to, among
other symptoms,
tetany, and a lot
of heat production.
This causes clinically
a hypermetabolic
state with hyperthermia,
the temperature can
exceed 106 degrees,
so it can be life
-threatening, severe muscle
contractions, tetany,
tachycardia,
tachypnea, and it
occurs in
predisposed patients
with that
inherited mutation.
The treatment is
dantrolene because
it is a ryanidine
receptor antagonist.
So dantrolene, tetany,
hyperthermia, and
here's another question.
Okay, so once again,
you can go ahead
and try to answer
it because I think
it's pretty clear,
but the answer is
next if you want to
look at that. Okay.
And so we'll just go
over it. That's a 25
-year-old male. Okay.
Appendectomy in the OR.
After a few minutes of
getting succinylcholine,
hypertension,
tachypnea,
elevated
respiratory rate,
temperatures elevated.
So, a mutation
in which of
the following is likely,
okay, and we went
over all of the,
well, we didn't go
over this one, but
I'm assuming you went
over this sometime
during your
hematopoietic lectures,
and so, what are
we looking at here?
Well, the Rheanodyne
receptor, but
malignant hyperthermia,
hyperthermia.
Okay, next is going to be
some congenital
myopathies.
And once again,
there's going to
be a mutation of a
gene that affects
the brianidine
receptor, you
know, like I was
mentioning earlier.
It's just not only
the hypothermia,
something like
central core disease.
The clinical
features are going
to be hypotonia at
birth, okay? So,
it's just a
different mutation.
It's associated with
other abnormalities,
but can include
malignant hypothermia.
And so, central
core disease,
because what
they found when
they were staining
for different
enzymes and proteins
within a muscle biopsy,
this is a cross
-section, is that the
central region shows
areas of reduced enzyme
activity and just appear
as a clear vacuole,
sometimes in the
center, sometimes more
at the periphery, and
so that's why it's
named central core
disease. It helps with
the diagnosis and
then you probably do
mutation molecular
studies to determine if
this was a mutation
that a person may have.
Another one is called
nemaline myopathy, and
nemaline myopathy
is, once again,
inherited autosomal
dominant or recessive.
They found some genes
that are affected.
And those mutations
of protein involve
the thin filament
actin, the sarcomere.
So there's going
to be contractile
dysfunction and
protein aggregates,
which lead to damage
of muscle fibers.
And that leads to
muscle weakness.
So, it will appear
as, at birth, the
floppy baby syndrome,
and it's called nemoline
because there will
be thread-like
rods, best seen in a
longitudinal section.
I have here a cross
-section, and you can
kind of see what the
rods would look like,
but they look like
spindle-shaped particles,
you know, actin fibers
are not developing
correctly, so they're
aggregating with each
other. and they can
appear as dark areas just
below the plasma
membrane or within the
sarcoplasmic reticulum
and you kind of see
some dark speckling here
and you know a spindle
shaped area right
there and over here you
see something over
over there okay it's
best to get additional
stains so if If you were
specializing in
muscle pathology, you
probably want to get
a Gomorrah's trichrome
because that makes them
show up more clearly.
Next are going
to be disorders
of lipid or
glycogen metabolism.
So once again,
another inherent disorder
that's disrupting
proteins that function
within the body.
There are general
patterns clinically
of muscle dysfunction.
So, symptomatic
people who exercise
or fast with
some of these disorders
can experience
muscle cramping
or rhabdomyolysis.
Or, and that'll be
periodic because
it's when you
exercise or when you
fast. It's not
all the time. Or,
they're going to be
slowly progressive
muscle damage. No
episodic symptoms.
There are some
examples, and we'll talk
about each of these.
This carnitine
palmitoyotransferase 2
deficiency involves free
fatty acid transport
into the myocondria.
Myoposphorylase
50, which is also
known as McCardle's
disease, has
episodic damage
in myoglobinuria.
Acid maltase, pompeze
disease, impairs
lysosomal conversion
of glycogen to glucose.
And now we'll start to
go over these ones. Okay,
carnitine,
pomatomotransferase
2 deficiency,
the most common
disorder of
lipid metabolism.
So you get a
toxic buildup of
fatty acids in
the cytosol or
the sarcoplasm
muscle cells.
And that impairs
transport, it's due to
impaired transport
into the mitochondria.
So you get episodic
damage, again, with
exercise or fasting.
so remember that.
And clinically,
you'll see hypotonia,
you might see dilated
cardiomyopathy.
So given that, what
you know right there,
you might do
molecular studies to
help confirm what
you're thinking about.
The next one
will be McArdle
disease. It's also
known as type 5
deficiency, and it
has an inability
to break down
glycogen, and here's
type 5, so there's
going to be an
enzyme here that
allows that process
to be done, so you
get a buildup of
glycogen within
the muscles.
So remember, painful
muscle cramps,
myoglobinuria,
arrhythmia because of
electrolyte imbalances,
normal blood
glucose because
the liver is unaffected.
There is a test
that you can do
in this case,
it's the lactate
ammonia test, so
during exercise,
so this is episodic,
that helps you with
determining what you
might be dealing with.
The venous lactate
curve is flat,
so normally with exercise
that rises, just
like ammonia,
but it's flat compared
with a normal rise,
so I can give you a big
clue that this might
be what you're dealing
with, the cartiloses.
The treatment here,
because it's a
disorder of
carbohydrates, is to
limit carbohydrates
and have a careful
exercise routine.
Pompe's disease, that's
type 2 deficiency,
once again, impaired
breakdown of
glycogen, but this
involves the lysosome,
and it's a clinical
feature, it's
going to involve
the heart, so you
can have hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy,
liver and muscles can
be affected. And the
hypoconia can be severe
and present in infancy,
there's exercise
intolerance deficiency,
mild deficiency will
affect respiration,
and early death
in patients with
general systemic type
symptoms are seen.
Here is the treatment,
sometimes enzyme
replacement of this
enzyme right here,
isosoma acid alpha
one for glucosidase,
replacement works for
some patients, not all.
Now we're going to talk
about mitochondrial DNA.
Okay because you have
the word mitochondrial
here, it's a disorder
that involves
mutations of
mitochondrial DNA, so it's
going to have a
maternal inheritance.
All the children
are going to be
affected by an
affected female.
So there's mutations
in impaired
ATP generation,
so there's going
to be low ATP in
various muscles.
But not just
muscles, because
mitochondria are
throughout your body.
But it affects
skeletal muscles and
other tissues
prominently that have a
high ATP requirement,
like cardiac muscle,
so the dysrhythmia
can be seen, even
neurons, seizures
can be seen. And
there's a syndrome
that we're going to
talk about next
called MIRF syndrome.
And I probably
should have put
drug treatment
there for that.
But we can go over
it real quick.
So drugs that
improve cellular
respiration, and
these are some.
They're not highlighted,
but metformin,
creatine, L
-carnitine, clonazepam,
barmyoclonus,
manicomulsants.
Some of the signs
you'll see with skeletal
muscles will be
weakness and an increase
in serum CK or CPK,
creatine phosphokinase,
or sometimes it's
called creatine kinase,
and even rhabdomyolysis.
Weakness is variable, but
here it tends to involve
the muscles around
the eyes, and there's
going to be chronic
progressive, what's
called external
ophthalmoplegia. So, the
muscles that are
external to the eyes will
be affected and not
function properly.
So,
extracurricular muscles,
eyelids, eyebrows,
blurred, double vision.
And that's a common
feature in mitochondrial
vessel nerves.
Now we're going to talk
about this MRF syndrome.
And MRF stands for
myoclonic epilepsy.
So, myoclonus is going
to be involved with
ragged red fibers. And
ragged red fibers refers
to a particular stain,
in this case, the
modified Gamori
trichrome. And I mentioned
that would have been
useful in an emily broad
myopathy because you'll
see these red-purple
aggregates within
damaged muscle fibers.
So that's where the
ragged red fibers come
from, red deposits
and the muscle stain.
And, let's see, those
red deposits are
going to show the
accumulation of affected
mitochondria in the
sub-sarcalemal region
of the myofibers. The
laboratory will show
serum creatine kinase
will be elevated.
Alright, so
clinically, it will be
characterized predominantly
by intermittent muscle
twitches, so-called
myotonous and it'll
be progressive myoclonus
myoclonus involves
the sudden jerks
that can occur and
there are some that are
happening in healthy
people for example
hiccups or a form of
myoclonus or those
sudden jerks and some i
don't know i've
experienced it i'm assuming
others have, also
called sleep starts.
Sleep starts just
before falling
asleep and these
occur in healthy
people and really
form a problem.
Weakness is going to
happen in the limb
girdle, shoulder, pelvic
muscles initially,
and then progressive
stiffness, spasticity,
and I mentioned how
to diagnose this
with the muscle biopsy,
and the seizures,
in addition to
myoclonus, they can be
generalized tonic
-clonic, absent seizures,
atonic, and I mentioned
the Mori-trichrome
stain that shows the
ragged red fibers.
There's another form
of mitochondrial
neuropathy called
Leber's Hereditary Optic
Neuropathy, and
that's mentioned here
because it commonly
presents with, again,
just like a lot of
these mitochondrial
myopathies, but
predominantly with chronic
progressive external
ophthalmoplegia.
And it does, it
primarily affects adult
males and it's a
different mitochondrial
mutation from
this MRF syndrome.
So it's going
to be having a
different presentation
predominantly
affecting the
eye muscles.
Okay, now we'll
look at, okay,
so as it says
here, inflammation
affecting your muscles.
These are going to
be immune mediated,
not infectious,
involving your skeletal
muscles. So you'll
see immune cells,
also antibodies that
will be pathogenic.
The primary symptoms
are going to be weakness
and pain of the
muscle myalgias. And
here's the examples,
and we'll discuss these.
Dermatomyositis.
It's a rare disorder
involving inflammation
in the skin.
The peak age is
going to be 50 to 60,
more common in females,
and it's immune
-mediated. What the
immune reaction is
affecting is the
small blood vessels of
the muscles that lead
to muscle damage.
It gradually worsens
over weeks to
months, and it can
last for several
years and resolve as
an immune-mediated
disease, or it
can be lifelong.
There are treatments
that can be done.
Things to
remember, I want
to remember a
presentation.
It has a classic skin
rash. Remember lilac
or heliotrope rash.
I'll show you an image.
Red-purple rash, eyelids,
periorval edema.
You can also
have skin manifestations.
I mentioned here,
Gotron's papules.
That's scaling red
eruptions, dusky
patches on the knuckles,
elbows, and knees.
Proximal muscles
are weak first, but
there are other
disorders that affect
proximal muscles and
eventually progress.
And the 10 foot,
this is good to
remember, it helps
you characterize what
kind of disorder
you're dealing with.
Symmetric, slow
onset, muscle pain,
you can produce
dysphagia if the
muscles of swallowing
are affected. It
can have extra
muscular involvement,
including lung
disease, myocarditis.
Good thing to
remember, I highlighted
malignancy here. 24%
with dermatomyositis
have malignancy,
and I list several
of them here that
have them associated.
So, once again,
autoimmune disease.
So, for some reason,
your body's been
stimulated to make
antibodies that
actually attack tissues
in your own body.
Small vessel damage,
capillaries are attacked.
antibodies in complement,
would produce ischemic
myocyte necrosis.
Cause is unknown,
so just like with
a lot of autoimmune
diseases, there's
genetic, immunologic, and
environmental factors
that have been
indicated, and it's
still being sorted out.
Some things they have
found in people are
anti-MI2 antibodies
that are associated
with the skin disorder,
the dotron-pactyl and
heliotrope crack,
heliotropic crash, or
just heliotrope. Anti
-JO1 antibodies are
associated with lung
disease and arthritis.
Since autoimmune,
these antibodies
are coursing through
your circulation,
affecting
different tissues.
Also, you can have
arthritis, lung
disease, and you
can also have what's
called a mechanic hand
rash. And I'll just
show you that here.
You've got cracked,
roughened skin
resulting on the tips
and lateral aspects
of the fingers.
So, you know, mechanics
use their hands
a lot, and sometimes
they end up
with dry, cracked
hands with a dirty line
appearance, and
that's what you can
see, even if they're
not a mechanic.
These are Gotron's
papules, and
you see these
erythematous patches.
and here's the
heliotrope rash
associated with
dermatomyositis.
Alright.
Okay.
Some diagnostic aspects
of dermatomyositis
in order to confirm
what you think based
on your clinical history
and presentation.
A biopsy might
be indicated
and what you
would look for is
part of the immune
system complement
within the capillary
beds. Histologically,
you'll see perifascicular
inflammation,
atrium, myofibers,
and loss of vessels.
And what you'll find are
a lot of inflammatory
cells there in that
location. Those tend
to be CD4-type T helper
cells. And when we
say perifascicular,
so here is a group of
muscle fibers being
surrounded by what's
called the epimysium,
and what you'll see, so
this will be a fascicle,
and the perimysium
is going to surround
muscle fibers, create
a fascicle. And out
here, you'll see the
inflammatory process
affecting these. You see
that they're shrunk.
Some are trying to
regenerate. This one's
got a blue hue, so that
these ones, but some of
them are losing their
stain because they're
becoming necrotic.
This one's actually a
bit hypertrophied, you
know, trying to recover
some of the muscle
function of this group
of muscle fibers here.
So peripesticular
atrophy, and that's, this
is good to remember,
it'll be in a paramesian
infiltration in a
paramesial distribution,
and here's the
paramesium around this
fascicle. You can also
see it here, where
you have atrophy occurring
and degeneration.
So we talked about
the autoantibodies, so
blood tests can be done
to check for those.
they'll have increased
creatinine kinase
due to muscle damage
treatment because
it's immune and will
be immunosuppressives.
Now this is polymyositis.
So polymyositis is
going to be similar
to dermatomyositis.
It is an inflammatory
disease, just like
that, and it's
immune-mediated,
non-infectious,
affecting proximal
muscles like the other,
but no skin involvement,
mainly in adults.
Peaconset is here,
remember that. It
can affect the heart,
lungs, blood vessels,
and women are more
often affected.
Once again, it
can last several
years and resolve
or be lifelong.
What you'll see that's
causing this problem
is immune cells,
in this case it's
going to be CD8
cytotoxic T-cells, which
produce tissue damage.
There's no vascular
injury in contrast
to dermatomyositis.
Once again, not genetic,
but it's not fully
understood, you know,
how this disease
occurs. There are risk
factors, just like a
dermatomyositis or other
autoimmune diseases.
Having an autoimmune
disease is a risk
factor for having another
autoimmune disease.
And what you'll see
is not paramezial
inflammation and
myocyte degeneration,
but you'll see
endomiesial
inflammation, so
individual myofibers.
And you'll find
prominently CD8 cells
in that region of
the necrotic and
regenerating muscle
fibers, and that's going
to be scattered
throughout the basical.
There's going to be no
perifascicular like
dermatomyositis.
Clinically, just
like dermato, you'll
see myalgia,
proximal muscle
weakness, increased
creatinine kinase,
and treatment,
once again, to me,
disorder, immunosuppressive
agents. All
right, so this next
slide compares these
two disorders. I
already showed you
dermatomyositis. This is
an image of polymyositis
in a cross-section
of a muscle, stained
with H&E. And you can
see a lot of small
cells with non
-autocytoplasmic nuclei.
Those are immune
cells. And they're
surrounding the endomysium
of individual muscle
fibers, you know,
scattered throughout.
And you'll see some
atrophy as you shrink.
And this is a good
stain over here.
So CD8 cells,
endomysial inflammation.
Dermatocytes has
perimesial inflammation,
CD4 cells, complement
activation.
Okay, once again,
here's the perimesium
around the
fascicle. Here's the
endomysium around
individual muscle fibers.
Inclusion body myositis.
That is the most common
inflammatory
myopathy in patients
above 68 years
old. Once again,
unclear pathogenesis,
really unclear if
it's inflammatory or
degenerative. What
you'll see, but there's
a degeneration of
those muscle fibers.
You'll see distal
muscles involved first,
contrast with dermato
and poly, that's going
to be proximal, and
it can be asymmetric,
that contrasts these
two disorders as well.
It's going to be slowly
progressive weakness,
most severe in the
quadriceps and distal
extremities. There
can be dysphagia
as well if those
muscles are affected.
And it's called
an inclusion
body because
what you'll find
are degraded organelles
within the sarcoplasm
of these muscle
fibers. And you can
see they can be at
the periphery more
centrally, but a lot
of degraded organelles.
They contain a
lot of cytoplasmic
other contents
in the myofibers.
You could see,
well you will
see, CD8 endomesial
infiltration
similar to
polymyositis, but
it's not going to
be as prominent,
but you can find
that, and it
might have something
to do with the
degeneration of
these myofibers.
And you'll find
a different
antibody than the others,
there'll be CN1A antibody
positive in about
half of them, and a
moderately increased
CK, and treatment is
immunosuppressives
and IVIG, intravenous
immunoglobulin, helps
as well, it's an
immunomodulator, but
that's not as
effective as the other
inflammatory myopathies,
so remember the age and
what you see in the
myofibers, and you'll
see what are called
inclusion bodies, so
degenerated organelles
with some of these
bodies can have
vacualizations of them.
And once again, this is a
Gomorya trichrome stain.
So the diagnosis of
these inflammatory
myopsies involves
clinical symptoms,
laboratory, and biopsy.
You can also do EMG
studies, and I don't
go into great detail
about that, but there
are certain signs
looking for neurogenic
and myopathic
findings, and there's
going to be a mixed
pattern in these
inflammatory myopathies.
So you send
someone to the lab
and they'll do
EMT and that
would confirm
what you think.
It could be an
inflammatory myopathy.
Here's a question.
Once again, you can maybe
try to answer
it on your own.
The answer is on
the next page.
If you can just
look at this right
away, here's a
biopsy H&E stain. And
you see a lot of
these lymphocytes.
And so here's
the endomysium,
okay, so the
fibrovascular layer
around the
individual myofibers.
And you see some
of them, this one
looks a little
more blue, this one
more blue. So these
could be at the beginning
of regenerations.
They've got
central nuclei.
These ones are going
to be affected.
And these, well,
there's another
one that's affected.
There's another
one that's
shrinking, losing
its coloration of
the sarcoplasm.
So,
endomesial. But
let's look at this.
35-year-old female.
Difficulty washing her
hair and
ascending stairs.
So, muscle girdle.
Proximal muscle
is affected.
It's been going on
for about six months.
Okay, so she wasn't
born with this.
It's something
that just started.
No other complaints.
So, he orders a biopsy,
and this is
what they find.
They see endomesial
inflammation,
lymphocytes. So what's
the diagnosis? We
just went over this.
What we're looking
at here is polymyositis,
endomesial.
Next two disorders,
myasthenia gravis
and Lambert-Eaton,
myasthenic syndrome.
They're shown here.
The disorders,
etiology on the right
is Lambert-Eaton,
and on the left,
myasthenia gravis. And what
you see here are
pathogenic antibodies,
myasthenia gravis,
acetylcholine receptor.
Lambert-Eton
antibodies to the
calcium channel on
the axon terminal.
Okay,
so we'll just go over
these real quick.
They're autoimmune,
these autoantibodies are
attacking body zone
tissue for some reason.
But we'll look
at some of the
clinical and
diagnostic features
to help distinguish them.
So, myasthenia,
autoimmune
mediated loss
of acetylcholine
receptors, and
we see that here,
autoantibodies, and
again, destruction
of the receptor,
so you have a
limited response of
acetylcholine due
to the lack of
sufficient receptors.
Okay,
so some clinical
features that are going
to help distinguish
these two and give
you clues that this
is going to be the
disorder you're dealing
with is young females
20 to 40 but there's
a bimodal distribution
it could be older
males and women are
most commonly affected
if it arises before
the age of 40 if
this disorder. Okay,
painless weakness
and with fatigue it
gets worse with repeated
exertion. Right.
Diplopia and ptosis if
those muscles
are affected.
And good to remember
that thymic abnormalities
are associated.
So part of the
immune system that
controls generation of
immune cells and
antibodies is abnormal.
So you can see
that especially in
young patients, and
what you may find
is thymoma or
thymic hyperplasia.
Young people,
10% have thymoma,
30% in patients who
are usually younger
have hyperplasia.
So there's, once
again, EMG studies that
can be done.
Electrophysiology is checking
the muscles, and
you'll have decreased
response with repeated
stimulation. So
it gets worse with
repeated exertion.
Nerve conduction
studies show that the
conduction of the
acupotensils are normal.
Treatment is going to
be acetylcholinesterase
inhibitors.
Try that first
because that inhibits
acetylcholinesterase.
So that will increase
acetylcholine
and you'll get reverse
muscle weakness.
So it's kind of a
confirmatory test.
Other treatments are going
to be plasmapheresis,
which is an
attempt to remove
antibodies from the
plasma of the individual.
immunosuppressive, it's
an immune disorder,
and thymectomy if
they have a thymoma.
Compare that to
Lambert-Eaton.
Okay, with Lambert
-Eaton, this is
rare. It affects
males in contrast to
females. It's
autoimmune disorder.
The peak age is around
35 years with the
onset, but a larger
peak occurs at 60 years.
So it This disorder,
just like myasthenia
gravis, can occur
for many years,
or it can be a
lifelong disorder.
Pathogenesis
is, once again,
autoantibodies, but
this time against
the presynaptic
calcium channel.
That prevents
acetylcholine release,
because without
calcium influx,
this vesicle
won't release
acetylcholine
across the synapse.
and clinically to
distinguish it from
myasthenia is that
they have muscle
weakness but it
improves with exertion
contrast myasthenia
there can be autonomic
symptoms such as dry
mouth constipation
and 50% so it's
important to remember
have an associated
malignancy
and I list a
couple of them here
so with all these
autoimmune diseases
Patients may have another
autoimmune disease,
so that's a risk
factor for this
syndrome as well.
Diagnosis,
electrophysiologic
studies, EMGs.
Repetitive
stimulation in this
case improves
muscle response, so
the opposite of
myasthenia gravis.
Once again,
autoimmune disorder.
Drugs that increase
the release of
acetylcholine into the
synapse can be tried.
And then
immunosuppressive
agents, you know,
immune disorder.
okay here's another
question and the
answer is going to be
next so try to answer
it well I had a bunch
of stuff I didn't
do that but it's
okay the answer is
on the next page 21
year old 24 year old
female new onset of
blurry vision worse
at the end of the
day. Okay, so a lot
of use over eyes
and eye muscles, it
gets worse. And
drooping of the eyelids.
EMG findings are
significant for diminished
muscle response after
repeated stimulation.
So what's the
mechanism for this?
Oh, I'm already going
with the answer.
Oh, okay.
Here, antibodies
against acetylcholine
we're talking about
myasthenia gravis this
describes myasthenia
gravis this is the
cause of Lambert Eaton
syndrome and this is
going to be there's
a ryanodine receptor
mutation that no okay
ryanodine receptor
mutation and immune
mediated endomysial
inflammation okay so
it's not polymyocidins
Okay,
here are some, here's
a summary of the
disorders we've gone
over and just some,
a quick review,
just a couple of
slides of, you
know, some of the
major things of
these disorders.
SMA1, autosomal
obsessive, and
floppy baby
hypotonia. Duchenne's,
absent dystrophin,
pseudohypertrophy
of calf muscles,
Gower's sign.
Becker's, muscular
dystrophy,
partially functioning
dystrophin, less severe.
Myotonic dystrophy,
ion channel deficiency
due to this
trinucleotide repeat.
And with myotonia,
malignant hypothermia,
once again, This is
a ryanidine receptor
disorder, and that
causes increased
calcium release from the
sarcoplasmic reticulum,
and it's associated with
inhaled anesthetics
and succinylcholine,
at least a
hypermetabolic state.
Congenital
myopathies, once
again, ryanidine
receptor,
and it can lead
to hypotonia.
And then there's
nemaline rod
biopathy and floppy
baby syndrome,
once again, nemaline
rods on biopsy,
as seen with
gomorius trichrome.
And then lipid
metabolism, not there yet,
decreases diseases
of lipid metabolism.
The one we talked
about was carnitine
pulpitotransferase
II deficiency,
so that's impaired
transport to
free fatty acids
into the mitochondria
and build up
in the cytosol,
episodic is going
to be when you
have muscle damage,
weakness, pain,
with exercise or fasting,
okay,
and it can cause
disturbance of the
heart with dilated
cardiomyopathy.
Diseases of
glycogen metabolism,
remember
McCardle disease,
also has type 2
deficiency, Pompe disease,
I mean type 5
deficiency, McCardle's,
Pompe's is type 2
deficiency, and there's
the enzymes that are
affected. So those
are deficient, and
this is episodic muscle
damage with exercise,
painful cramps,
maybe myoclonaria,
and normal glucose, okay?
And then Pompe's disease
will show impaired
glycogen senses
within the lysosome,
it can also affect
the heart, those
muscles as well with
cardiomyopathy, and
they show exercise
intolerance of skin.
Minochondrial
myopathies, transmission
from the mother,
an affected
mother, impairs
ATP P-generation,
so tissues that
use a lot of ATP,
muscles, brain, those
will be affected.
I didn't mention
Miele syndrome.
There's a lot of
different disorders
where lactic acidosis
is occurring.
So, don't use that as
something that's going
to help you with
mitochondrial myopathies.
But you have elevated
CK, and these
are commonly
associated with chronic
progressive external
ophthalmoplegia.
and I've already
gone on for a
while so but
there's a lot of
diseases we left
out a bunch it
was the last slide too
okay last slide
is okay the
lecture feedback
form I'd appreciate
feedback. Well,
there it was,
but it's also in
the PowerPoint.
Sorry, I couldn't
show you here.
And so please
send feedback. I'd
appreciate that.
And email me with
questions, comments,
or call me.
Or if you're here in
Arkansas, just come
up to room 424F and
we'll have a chat.
And thank you for your
time and attention.